slayn singer christina grimmie was laid  to rest on thursday in her home state of  New Jersey the 22 year old was buried  just a week after her tragic death Adam  Levine who coached Christina on season 6  of The Voice paid for the funeral on  Friday fans paid their respects at a  public memorial and Medford New Jersey  et was on the scene when one person has  made such an impact in a community like  Christina has today's a day not just to  mourn her but today is a day to  celebrate the life that she's had and on  monday hundreds gathered for a  candlelight vigil where Christina's  brother Marcus spoke to the crowd about  her faith and love of life we're blessed  to someone a great piece right now she's  in a better place